[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on saki on very
excited to be talking about holistic
health and mindfulness we have Amanda
Vikram joining us today hello hi thanks
so much for coming on the show really
appreciate it thank you thank you for
having me it's been a super pleasure
learning about you also learning about
your through Susan Berman who we love
very much
you shout out to stew and only the
source and also the new program reset
which we've both been on we love so much
Amanda victims background for those that
don't know is a holistic health and
mindfulness coach helping people aligned
with their divine purpose she focused on
reducing stress preventing burnout
optimizing performance and shares these
impactful stories on her podcast called
driven for purpose and you can find
Amanda become calm her link in the bio
below as well as the podcast link her
youtube channel link which has some
great conversations highly recommend
checking that out as well as her face
book so let's start things off with one
of our favorite questions to intro the
episodes what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world
such a controversial topic I mean I
really feel that the direction of our
world depends on where you focus your
energy right I feel like a lot of people
think it's doomsday and like there's all
these things that we need to do and we
need to act quick or else we're going
down and I think that part of that may
be true and yet I also feel that if you
begin to focus your energy on the things
that are actually like all the people
who are making great changes and all the
amazing inventions and creations and
connected based communities and Inspira
inspiring projects then that's what
you're going to see as well so I think
like to target on one way or the other
and just say that I believe exactly this
or that would just put me in a place
that I'm not sure that I would want to
go down that rabbit hole but I feel like
it's where you focus and then tell us
more about that importance of focusing
on those positive ones yeah so where
your attention goes energy flows and
everybody's heard that right but that's
even in the quantum physics realm right
when we look at something and and we
focus our energy on it it changes and so
I feel that for anybody who is really
wanting to make a difference in the
world and anybody who's really wanting
to see the brighter side and the more
positive side which is hopefully
everyone we have the ability to focus on
all the things even if you just start
with the self right like what am i doing
right how am i showing up how am I
making myself better and encouraging
myself to step into this direction and
so that's kind of my two cents on
whatever it is that you want to see
happen put more of your energy and your
focus there and guess what that will
grow in case it's the manifestation of
the future I don't want to author but it
like you can recommend it it starts
within mm-hmm okay so what are I we'll
get to some of these tips that you that
you share with people to to help quickly
give us a speak to that importance of
at a deeper level of focusing on once
inward practice and then having that
reflect on what happens in the exterior
world as well as how that helps the
world yeah
so it's interesting when I first moved
to California I decided that I wanted to
be an author and I wanted to travel
around the world and write a book and
the title of my first book was going to
be thought it's to creation as
creationist to life and it really is
exactly that right so what you think
about
creates the story that you believe to be
true so we're all running some story in
our head there's a narrator and and the
truth is is that we're our own narrator
but if we're so busy getting all this
chatter and not taking the time to
separate to actually think about what is
the story that I'm creating is it does
it make me feel good do I feel good in
what I'm doing in my relationships and
my job and all of these different things
and if you don't then you have the key
to changing the story so I really
believe that if you are in a place of
really wanting to make a great shift
don't work on the changing something
external work on how can I change my
internal state so that my external
reality changes from here because this
is all we really have the power to
change after all
I really appreciated the kind of like a
mantra that it's the state not the story
so we kind of can hold the state of
inner peace and oneness and then unity
and if we can hold that throughout a
majority of our day then we can achieve
things that we previously just didn't
think we're mad imaginable yeah have you
ever listened to by chance Abraham Hicks
heard okay yes and have you heard of Joe
Dispenza yeah so have you listener read
his latest book becoming supernatural
yes okay I got lucky and was introduced
to a becoming supernatural so if
anybody's listening check out that book
right so and what's really beautiful is
I've been listening to Abraham Hicks
maybe since for seven years and what
they say and what he is now proving
through quantum physics and and biology
and science it's all the same and it's
all about just you're at your own
vibrational state but it's it's so easy
it's challenging right because it's like
right in front of us and we want to
continue to grasp outside but all we
have to do is just like start feeling
and I saw that you have a practice of
gratitude which is like one of the best
things that you could do to to shift
that state yes oh this is gonna be so
good all these practices that were about
to hit okay but you you introduced us to
just starting the journey you started
kind of introducing us to the journey
but born in Pasadena then went to
Colorado from before till 18 and then
found yourself back in California doing
all the yogic work that you've been
doing the last ten years and I hope to
vitality path so tell us about this
journey yeah I was actually funny I was
on the it's a big turning point for me
because I'm actually closing my
California Chapter I'm closing my
America chapter but more specifically
California has been just like my heart
and my soul and I was on the phone with
my mom on the way over here and I'm like
it's really interesting because I'm
about to drive back to Colorado with a
new car and all of my stuff which isn't
very much and like come back but ten
years ago I was on my way out here and I
was driving and I remember passing I was
in my little Mustang like my first car
packed with stuff and I was coming to
California and I remember I crossed the
state
line and all I had from California was
like hopes and dreams like I didn't have
any job I wasn't in line for college
there was nothing like I quit college to
come to California just for this idea of
what was possible and like my soul knew
it it was like you have to go back to
California you know you were born here
and you didn't get to live the
California life so like you have to do
it at least and try and yeah I ended up
like I remember crossing the California
state line I mean like crying and like
my friend was driving and I was like
trying not to let him know you know I'm
like what the hell are you doing what
are you doing you know and the truth is
that 10 year journey has just taken me
on such a ride of the self right like
when I left everything that I knew my
friends my family there was nothing here
I started all over and it was like okay
well what do you want to build like here
you are in a place that you have no
strings no ties no nothing all you have
is this vision and this idea and this
deeper root knowing that you're supposed
to be here for some reason and that has
led me on you know a very challenging
journey like very emotional times where
I'm like what in the world like why am I
here it's expensive it's challenging
it's hard you have to hustle all these
things like I'm fighting with everybody
else feel like do the things I believe
in and yet also like the most growth and
the most beauty and the most amazing
opportunities and like there's something
about California it's like this vortex
of people especially in the Bay Area
like you have to work hard to be here
and I really have like a really
beautiful appreciation for anyone who's
here doing what they love because you
have to hustle in order to do it and you
just meet amazing people and not in that
world because of that I loved your story
of just this calling and just pursuing
what so many people say is these
greatest challenges or adversities
because right on the other side are our
greatest treasures but there's not an
instant gratification yeah this is
definitely at like a long-term bet and
when asked to persevere through the
continuous ups and downs and then they
find themselves so much more to
spiritually developed yeah
and I'm super happy that you took that
risk and that you have the story now
okay but you did a lot of crazy things
throughout you actually went and back
and forth three years in India yeah
also Southeast Asia Thailand Vietnam
Nicaragua planning to go to Europe 102nd
so tell us about what you've been
learning through these spiritual
endeavor Aang's outside of the United
States and how that's integrated into
this synthesis for you on this all these
spiritual practices that you now take in
that's probably one of my favorite
topics let's do it so you know again
it's its whole like deconstructing my
reality like I realized that where I
grow up was I was so conditioned by what
everybody else was doing and like
seeking connection from others and
seeking approval for others and wanting
this like reassurance that I'm on the
right path and I'm doing the right thing
and yet you know whether that's College
the programming that you need to go to
college or the programming that you need
to be a certain way and relationships or
whatever it is and you know I've always
kind of questioned that there's always
been something that's like is this
really me or is this me wanting to
appear that I'm this things that I can
be accepted or approved and so I
remember I think I was like 20 or 21 and
and my I was on this path to go to
Berkeley to finish college and do all
these different things and like nothing
was working for me I'd crammed in school
at San Diego to in order to transfer to
go to holistic health school and then
ended up like trying to find a place to
live and nothing was working and that
was the first moment where I was about
to freak out because I quit my job I was
like selling my apartment and I was
getting rid of all my stuff and I'm like
oh my gosh like everything I've worked
hard in order to do the right thing
nothing's working out what's going on
and it was in that moment of like about
to be panic that I was like stop okay
just take a moment and meditate and my
meditation journey began really really
young so I sat there and and I just kind
of calms my mind and came into this
space and it was like listen instead of
thinking that you know oh my god I've
tried so hard to make this thing happen
and it's not working what am I going to
do what if you could change your
perspective and what if it was you can
do
anything in the world that you want what
is it that you want to do and it was in
that moment that like kind of that the
clouds parted and the shine you know Sun
was shining and I was like whoa what a
what a mind state changed and that was
when I was like well I'd want to teach
yoga because I was into yoga at that
point and I already had my teacher
credentials and and I said well if you
could teach you anywhere in the world
where would where would you want to go
and I was like well India of course you
know and India is the birthplace of yoga
and so I wanted to learn with like the
actual juice of where it all came from
because American yoga everyone knows
who's in the path it's very very
different and so yeah two weeks later I
mean I remember two days later I called
my mom I said hey mom I'm going to India
I just got my ticket I'm leaving in
three weeks and so yeah three weeks
later Iowa drove my [ __ ] to Colorado and
went out to India and that was like that
was the beginning of like the real
soul-searching journey mmm okay top us
into what it's like when you land there
and you're exploring the yogic culture
and learning yeah so it's really
interesting because India actually felt
a lot like home to me
like I landed in Delhi and there was
this feeling of like ah this feels
strangely familiar you know which most
people they land in Delhi and they're
like what the hell is this place you
know but there was something about it
like the culture and the experience and
the richness of the land and you know
India is the the most challenging place
you will ever go like nobody really is
like oh I'm just gonna go on a holiday
to India like no it's it's challenging
it will test you in every way shape or
form your mental physical emotional
everything it will break you down so
that it can give you fertile land they
so you can regrow and that's even what
my first teacher did like I remember in
America I was really good at yoga and
many people were like wow look at all
these things you can do did it and then
I go to my teacher and he's like he just
ripped me apart like I remember the
first time I'm thinking I might not like
super good you know and
even just still at the very lair of
Astana but like I'm doing all these
things and he just ripped me apart and I
remember again like riding home and the
tooktook that night and just like crying
and being like wow like my whole
community back home was like wow you're
such a good teacher such a good student
that it uh and I know nothing and from
that day on I've been you know
continuing to travel and to see him and
my Austin on my practice in my
relationship to yoga has drastically
changed but I remember that like him as
a teacher as a metaphor for what India
did for me it ripped me apart and made
me question everything that I thought
was me and broke me down many times and
gave me this opportunity to say well now
who are you
without all your stories it's a
recurring theme the people that sit with
us on the show that teach us that when
they have their worldview augmented to
such a degree where it's almost as
though it kind of like falls apart a
little bit and then they piece it back
together in a way that is more aware
yeah
that we love that we love that we think
that's like one of the most important
things to be able to do and it requires
a high degree of open mind in this and a
high degree of one's ability to like set
conscientious goals and execute on them
like you were exceptional here and then
you went there and you realize that you
have so much more to still learn and so
you had that humility to be able to do
so so then okay there's still a lot to
learn about this this exploration of
yours but let's focus on the most
profound realizations for you in this
journey to India and Southeast Asia what
were them like most awakening aspects
well the first one was that like the
first trip I went it was like I was
searching searching for answers
searching for this searching for that
and it was almost like every time
universe just showed a mirror it's like
you keep looking for all the things
outside yourself just stop just stop and
look and realize that you have
everything you need within you and that
sounds really cliche but there are a
number of different synchronistic things
that kept happening and it kind of just
kept showing me like just just relax and
go within
and I feel like the biggest kind of the
biggest experience that Southeast Asia
at least has kind of taught me was just
that there's a lot of wisdom and the
experiences around you and yet also it's
it's it's you're the interpreter of
everything that's going around you know
and everything is kind of like a mirror
image of one another and so going abroad
just really helped me deconstruct all of
who I thought it was because I also
travel alone as well and you know I
posted something on Facebook the other
day like loneliness is comes about when
you're disconnected from yourself and
like being alone not speaking my
language being by myself like navigating
these lands like there's a lot of time
where I'm just sitting with myself where
I don't have TV or friends or drugs or
alcohol or food to distract me I'm just
sitting in my [ __ ] and like a lot of it
is coming up but yet when I'm having to
deal with that I'm not starting to see
that if I'm having a bad interaction
with someone or my environment or things
aren't going out well it's because of me
I mean trust was huge like when I land
in this country I have no idea if this
taxi is gonna I'm landing at 2:00 in the
morning I have no idea if he's gonna
take me to the actual place that I'm
supposed to be dropped off like I
literally had to surrender and just
trust trust in myself first and foremost
and the decisions that I'm making and
that they're in alignment and also trust
in like the bigger thing that's guiding
me and if at any point I started to
contract and started to create fear then
there would be hiccups in my journey
left and right and so I think like trust
and surrender are like the two pieces
that if you could do anything like just
trust in yourself and in the path and
surrender to whatever is being handed to
you maybe not as what you want but as
the gifts of what you actually need
yeah those are great surrender and also
this mirror that you talk about is so
critical to to be able to really said
it's cliche but it's so true though that
digging deep within ourselves really
unleashes our fullest potential and
actually being at peace and that quiet
you said there's no instantaneous
gratification distractions to be able to
pull you away and even the socialization
you can't just they call it the Fran and
go and hang out with them type thing so
you're forced to look in the mirror
you're forced to have these things come
up and for you to engage with them and
spiritually grow in that presence and
actually it's a reoccurring theme of the
leaders of the last thousands of years
that the most profound creative moments
at a lot of the time come from being in
complete silence and stillness and away
from the distractive fabric that we've
built in many ways okay let's talk about
the connecting with the sole purpose
because the last three years has been
vitality past mm-hmm you've been rocking
it teach us about this connecting with
the soul's purpose and how you've been
engaging with clients on this yeah
so it's interesting because like in the
beginning it started off as yoga right
and and people who are coming to like
connect with their physical being and
then through yoga obviously when you
start to connect to the physical you
start to realize that well what I put
into the physical vessel has a lot to do
with what I'm able to get out of it
whether it be your physical ability or
your mental emotional capacity and then
you take that a little bit deeper and
it's like okay well I'm in alignment
with my physical being I'm an alignment
with the way that I'm mentally like
operating but then what is it all about
what am I here for
and so people started coming to me
feeling that okay I have the house I
have the car I have the whatever it is
that we've been again constructed to
believe that will bring us happiness and
and bless everyone who's you know told
us that that we need this reality of
safety and security because let's say
our grandparents and our parents they
come from Wars and and and you know
depression is a Great Depression and
things like that at least over here in
America and so it's really important to
then come back to okay well we're
changing drastically so what is it that
I'm here for like it's not about like I
can make a ton of money and I'm super
stressed out like a lot of my past
clients have been in the Bay Area and
they're you know working at tech
companies or they're really good at
whatever it is and they're making a lot
of money and they're just like soulless
they're like I don't feel connected to
my body I don't feel connected to my
community I don't feel connected to what
I'm actually here for I don't understand
this is what everyone told me was the
golden ticket and I'm doing it and I'm
just really depressed and miserable and
so yeah feeling into that and like then
that means like okay am i living my
truth or am i living someone else's
truth and who what is my truth and how
do I find that truth and where do I
begin and so that's when there's like
inner journey for the individual comes
to light where the person stops sinking
and stops going outwards and start
saying okay like I'm ready to tune in
and say like what is my purpose what is
my gift what is my calling what turns me
on what makes me alive what makes what
ignites me what am i passionate about
but if we're so busy trying to get and
trying to achieve then we forget what's
bringing the vitality which I explain to
people what's the difference between
energy and vitality right energy is
determined upon the outside how much
sleep you got how much food you ate you
know how much stress you have but
vitality is this wellspring within you
that's just waiting to be tapped into
and so that's kind of how the vitality
path was spun okay Wow so we're we're
sort of funneling humans into the
economic machinery within metropolis and
when we do that we have described these
crisis Issy's that emerge where people
say what am I doing here and am I
actually following my true purpose yeah
in life and so then that's a fascinating
first sort of
tapping into Who am I really am I and
then further is that this word vitality
I think is so beautiful this is the sort
of the state of of that wealth spring
within us is always with us that states
always with us but then it's up to us to
tap into it and so it's not as to do so
it is is but it does have interplay with
that sleep and nutrition yeah yeah okay
so teach us more about it yeah so I mean
first of all like people that when they
start to it they start to feel this
there's usually something that happens
to the physical body you know that could
be like for instance burnout right you
get burnt out you have stress you have
depression you have anxiety all these
things are not normal and a pill is the
worst model like oh let's just put a
bandaid on it and pretend that it
doesn't exist no you have to get to the
root like why is this actually happening
yeah
and so like getting to that space and
oftentimes people can relate through
either mental emotional distress or
physical distress and that's how you
kind of capture them it's like oh my
body's not functioning I'm having a lot
of gas I'm having a lot of bloating I
having this weird skin thing that won't
go away I'm having severe depression I
need anxiety I can't sleep at night I
have no energy all of these things is
your beautiful vessel trying to tell you
listen to me I'm trying to guide you I'm
trying to help you why are you fighting
me
like I promised we're on the same team
just listen and yet we're so conditioned
to be believe and to be distracted like
food is a distraction alcohol is a
distraction like even all of our like
entertainment and [ __ ] is a distraction
you know and so it's like we're
constantly distracted and a lot of the
food I mean even coming back to America
there's like by me signs everywhere from
like food to booze to close to this so
that you know and like all of the
different the news and all of the
different you know TV shows that people
are into and there's nothing wrong with
it I don't want to place judgment on it
and I just want to place awareness of
the fact that they're all distractions
pulling you away from like what's really
wanting to be felt we don't know how to
feel our emotions anymore especially
like the models that we teach our men
like toughen up be a big boy like put
your big-boy pants on like don't show
your emotions and this goes for everyone
but like we don't even know how to feel
anymore we don't even know how to slow
down and just say hold on let me stop
projecting my [ __ ] onto you and we're in
a relationship and all the things that
you're doing wrong and let me actually
take this mirror and shine it back into
myself and say what's going on with me
what am I afraid to feel and why am i
reaching to food even if it's healthy or
yoga or exercise or like anything can be
an addiction Koff anything can be an
addiction work can be an addiction right
and it's like can I stop reaching to
these things to fulfill me and I can I
start actually sitting with myself and
feeling what wants to be felt you know
pain just wants to be felt it just wants
to be given the space and the permission
to be not for you to say hey I shouldn't
be feeling this it shouldn't be how it
is shaming yourself it should be about
actually connecting to and creating
compassion for what's alive in you and
when we do that all of a sudden all this
tension and holding on starts to melts
away we understand the act of surrender
and then that's when everything just
starts flowing because we realize it's
not about us it's not about our egos or
our minds or what we want or a part of
something much greater and so
yeah yeah you're on fire okay Wow
yeah and I wonder how much different
this is than the East eastern part of
civilization especially Asia it does
very much seem like the buy me signs are
everywhere the addictions to food and
and drugs and and entertainment networks
and anything that's not tapping into our
deepest senses of purpose and emotion
you said give it that space I used to
spend more time trying to quell the
emotion and then I and then I started
letting it emerge and cry with it and
you know I feel it as pain painted you
know sometimes you feel it and you're
just like I shouldn't you know feel it
for so long there's probably a line
where you're just like okay well maybe
getting caught the story in the drama
yeah yeah yeah so there's these
intricate intricate balances so then
maybe it is true that for some of us the
purpose on this color we love complexity
that each one of us are these colors
some of us find our greatest alignment
and purpose with the hustle sure that we
want to build and focus on building we
don't want to go and do the
entertainment and all that other stuff
but maybe for other people their color
is to do the entertainment yeah but then
how do we solve the biggest world
challenges if everyone's enter doing the
entertainment thing we're not tackling
the world challenges so how do you feel
about there being a color let's say on
the wheel the ones that are maybe
tackling the greatest challenges do you
feel like they have a that we have a
deeper level of importance for that
color on the wheel explain this to me a
little bit more when I make sure that
I'm fully understand as in the ones that
are focused on tackling these challenges
and hustling on those versus ones that
are maybe just doing the entertainment
and the distractive things yeah yeah
well it's all it's all balanced right
it's all a spectrum and I think that
like one of the things that really
bothered me in the
to movement and masculine-feminine
situation is again this like this victim
mode this victim mentality or this like
we're better or like you know all of
this there's no you can't have one
without the other we are always seeking
balance but we'll never be in balance
because if everything was balanced and
there would be no life there would be
nothing to do there'd be nothing to
continue to create this Evan flow and so
I think that as we continue to wake up
as a society and as a collective more
and more people I mean you can be a
conscious creator right there is so much
that you can do and get involved in and
create and I mean like what you're doing
you know like there's so many ways to
contribute and to light up whatever it
is that makes you feel alive and do so
in a way that's beyond just numbing out
or just yourself
that's tapping into this greater
connectivity which is what we all want
at the end of the day like we all I
think the greatest thing right now most
people are feeling is the pain of
feeling alone and it's like well if you
connect to something greater and if you
funnel that into your purpose then all
of a sudden you have this opportunity to
to to continue to do the things you love
but do it in a more intentional way that
not only benefits you but it benefits
the greater consciousness and therefore
you're not doing it alone you're doing
it with people whether it's you know
felt on a logical level or just sensed
on an energetic level mmhmm yeah you
that's that's a great synthesis on on
the dichotomy between these different
colors on the wheel and their roles in
the greater
civilization that we live in yeah I'm
still trying to figure that one out just
it seems as though we need the ones that
are solving the problems in a greater
motive we motivate more to you know
otherwise we'll just funnel more into
the economic machinery without that
realization so all the things that
you're teaching us right now awaken and
inspire just like we aim to do with this
program I want to hear on the on the on
these things that you were mentioning a
little bit ago specifically you have
this bio individualized nutrition yeah
and and we seem in many ways to just be
in a crazy are we actually in control
are these microbes is there microbiome
in control yeah you're laughing that
that whole world is very interesting in
and of itself and I think that first of
all bio individuality means that like
you know better than anyone else there's
no diet
there's no specialist there's no doctor
there's no nothing that knows better
than you but the problem is is that
we've taken all of our own like agency
and put it into the hands of others and
say I don't know you're the specialist
tell me what's wrong with me and it's
like although yes like there are some
people who study these things forever
but you know your body better than you
but if you don't spend time getting to
know your body and getting to connect to
your body and getting to listen giving
it the space so that you can listen to
what it wants to what it's trying to
tell you then you're not gonna be able
to try to figure out its message message
or know what's best for you so bio
individuality is is understanding that
principle that like everyone is unique
and because you're unique what you need
is gonna be different than what I need
and and what amounts and in what
variations so the way that I work with
with nutrition with individuals I
actually have a it's called the system
reset detox program and it helps people
kind of gives people a structure to
strip out all of the things that are
kind of clouding their channel not only
in their physical body but also their
energetic and mental emotional bodies so
that they can come back to self as bare
bones as possible
without all of these like I'm not sure
what's causing what and then begin to
understand how different foods are
affecting them and their mental and
their emotional and their energetic and
their physical and it gives you
mindfulness based practices so that you
can be aligned and really listen to like
is this me am i reading this is this
really what's true for me and I think
that you know to answer your question is
it our microbes or is it us that are
more in control where all of that
everything is affecting everything you
know so if you think if you have a lot
of guilt when you're about to eat
something because you read it it's
really bad and guess what your body's
gonna say okay well there's there's
guilty this is bad let me put fat around
it and this is gonna be a toxin if you
don't that's why some people can like
drink and eat whatever and somehow
they're and smoke like a chainsaw and
they live to be like a hundred whereas
other people who are very you know my
gosh I'm trying to do all the right
things can like end up having a lot more
complications and so I think you know
taking agency and just remembering that
like you have the tools again within you
and yes there are some practices that
can help you find those tools and find
that alignment but ultimately you know
what's best for you but if you're too
busy being distracted and not listening
then you're not gonna be able to
understand the messages that your body
is communicating to you does that make
sense yes yes that is the bio
individualized program yeah and it seems
as though the newest scientific advances
especially into all the craziness into
the microbiome like the meta
transcriptomics almost crazy stuff to
potentially give us the scientific
insight that can kind of roll with us in
this whole I know what's best for me by
the way that I treat my food in the way
that I treat my eating cycles and how I
feel I kind of kind of potentially work
together and to essentially validate one
another
this is in addition to all of the other
things that you train with people on
this is not only this bio individualized
nutrition and it's also on the you
mention early reducing stress preventing
burnout optimizing performance
mindfulness and these are critical with
entrepreneurship and there's so many
people yes people that watch the show
that are either working within companies
where they're wearing tons of different
hats where they're running those
companies and they're just in many ways
trying to figure out what do I do I love
what I do if you're you loving what you
do awesome that's a huge first step yeah
if you don't then take a step back you
know think Cal recalibrate find what it
is but for those that do love but then
they're trying to figure out how much
time do I dedicate to what I love yes I
can be a challenge right and this is
like a huge thing so about two years ago
maybe almost three years ago now I
started to work only with entrepreneurs
because I as an entrepreneur saw this
cycle you're gonna work harder for you
won't work as hard for anyone else as
you do for yourself like you're gonna
like you it especially if it's your baby
and it's your passion problem and you
love it but like that also can be out of
balance we can be addicted to this thing
that we see or this vision or this
identity or this project or this passion
or whatever and it's all about balance
right so like making sure that yes this
is the thing that maybe ignites you but
too much fire will burn everything down
right so like taking a moment to step
back and saying okay like I love this
thing I'm dedicating a lot but what
parts of my soul or what parts are my
connections
am I not really connecting to like how
is my romance life maybe I'm dedicating
everything to this thing and I don't
have time for romance or I don't have
time for connecting to my physical body
and I'm a big fan of self worship right
so like worshiping my own physical
vessel or connecting to spirit so
there's all these other elements of us
besides our passion projects that in
order to continue to be this channel for
whatever wants to come through you all
things need to be balanced otherwise
again you'll burn
especially in entrepreneurship because
we love it so much you know yes yes Wow
okay there's so many things here how
many times have we wandered ourselves
into a romance and then realize that we
actually are learning tons of things
from the romantic intimacy that are
actually really applicable to everything
else that we do in our lives how many
times do we wander into taking two days
to go and do something on the beach or
in the woods or whatever and then we
realize all of the applicability to the
rest of our lives
while simultaneously I want to
potentially push back a tiny bit and
just say that for those that are
potentially attempting to you know
skyrocket themselves forward yeah that
if one looks at a human's as nodes in
their level of influence on the
trajectory of civilization are we just
wandering ourselves into the bar or into
areas that we may not actually find as
much of the higher level connections
that we want or are we may be wandering
ourselves more to these higher caliber
engagements with people that are
actually uplifting us you you know you
are the people you surround yourself
with what are your thoughts about that
it's all about balance you know it's
like when part like look at your
physical body and and and I feel that
you know the more that you start to
connect to the physical body the more
that you'll be able to ask yourself am I
in alignment or am I not in alignment
how's my stress levels how's my sleep
cycles how's my energy levels if you if
you're saying I'm freaking I'm really
good and not in adrenal fatigue or not
in like I'm on the edge of burnout and
like I'm doing all the stuff and I'm
getting everything done and everything
is great because look at all the things
I'm doing and like that is dangerous too
and I've been there right it's like
everything is great and oh my gosh I
don't know I'm like I'm so productive
and it it it and it's like yeah by like
is that coming from your wealth spring
or is that coming from your coffee and
from your excitement because of all the
people you're meeting and all the things
you're doing and if
surely you will burn out because your
body is wanting to always guide you it's
like keep drive tries put listen and
take a time if you're driving on this
destination you're trying to get there
take them on with your paws look at
where you are look at the landscapes
that are around you and you'll enjoy it
much more on that journey mmm yeah
that's great
yeah yeah I think that's a fantastic
piece of advice being in love with the
journey to the point where you're you're
able to to to slow down sit sit down
away from the tech and reflect on the
landscapes around you the social
networks that you've been able to build
the projects that you're working on and
how successful they're and appreciate
you and appreciate how far you've come
and appreciate all the times that it was
challenging and you're like what am i
doing like please send me an answer I
feel it but I don't know where I'm going
you know like appreciate those things
love yourself love yourself in this
expression of moving forward
because when you take the time like
gratitude and you appreciate you and all
parts of you guess what you're gonna
increase your vibrational frequency
which means you're gonna be open and
more receptive for more things to come
to you but if you're so focused on the
goal then you're gonna miss out you're
gonna get there and you really focus on
the next goal and you're gonna get there
and then all of a sudden 20 years from
now you're gonna look back and be like
wow I did all these things but was they
ever really present did they really get
to fully soak in all those moments and
how hard I worked or was a too busy
trying to get there only to realize that
I never really got there because I'm
still trying to get there
I think that's mm-hmm the ability to
sponge in the moments along the journey
to their fullest degree yeah to do it
consciously to be on the journey with as
much conscious sponging as possible like
that okay all right you've been you've
been working on actually sharing the
experiences as well with the people that
you're working with on your podcast on
the youtubes so tell us about what it's
like you know you've done like sixty
five-plus of these sometimes even to a
week so what is it like doing the depth
that dives into figuring out the sharing
of the experiences well that's like the
most fun part for me you know like as a
creator is someone who I really enjoy
creating and I really enjoy sharing and
like there's this vulnerability I'm
almost kind of over using that word just
because it's like almost overused at
this point but yet I'm consistently kind
of leaning into my edge of discomfort of
like whoa I'm having these a life
expanding experiences and I am no
different than anyone else I didn't come
from like a privileged background I just
came from middle-class you know like I
remember when I moved to California my
mom was like well you're on your own
like I'm not helping you out anymore and
this was like right when the the 2009
right after the crash happened and so
like she was just a little scary and
jobs were a little bit harder you know
but I think that moving in this
direction of like trying to understand
where it is your route is or where it is
you're going you know like taking full
agency is is really important in in
order to shift you know to shift to
where it is that you're that you're
wanting to go and so I totally forgot
the question you done the question just
about the shared experience happens so
sharing these experiences it's like I
find so much richness and being able to
take my experience and pull back from it
and be like whoa like I
this experience whether it was terrible
or whether it was amazing and then kind
of look at like what did I do in order
to create this experience and what did I
learn and then how can I share this with
others and a really like felt way so
that people can actually feel like
that's me I've been there but then not
continue to say stuck in this story but
actually pull themselves out and get
tools to begin to identify how they're
creating the story and then change it
from that place and so sharing you know
my journeys as I'm going all around the
world and having these like mind-blowing
experiences I share them number one to
inspire that anyone can do whatever it
is that you want to do as long as you
have the dedication the determination
and the mindset and and the tools as
well and the help and the support and so
it's kind of like this online conscious
community that's growing of people who
are starting to take their own agency
and apply it to their lives and it's
beautiful because it allows me to not
only have these experiences but then
also share it with others so that they
can continue to like vision for their
own lives if they're in a place that
they're not really excited about maybe
they're still in their hometown and
they're unhappy or you know they're in a
job and they're unhappy it's like how do
I get from here to there kind of a thing
yeah being able to provide the tools
that are needed and then the awareness
shift of all the tools that I need in
order to make these transitory moments
in my life actually come to fruition
a lot of this is that mindfulness is
these detox periods yeah yeah a lot of
it is that going with it yeah going with
it yeah
yeah okay okay understanding my sole
purpose my divine role in this big game
of civilization in believing like
believing that you matter
believing that like you make a
difference I mean think about it in a
vibrational standpoint regardless of who
you are regardless of what your story is
we are all vibrational beings like that
take it down to science if that's where
you want to go but our vibration
determines like how we feel right if we
feel good we're at a higher vibration if
we feel depressed and sad and lonely
we're at a lower vibration again nothing
is better or worse it just is but if you
want if you come in and you're feeling
likes like when you greeted me or like
hey how's it going I'm so excited it's
like wow that's a that's a that's a
higher frequency and that's attracting
more of that to you you get it interview
all these amazing people because your
energy is inspiring and higher but if
you're sitting here in this lower
vibrational state saying this story
about how this isn't fair and you're
playing victim mindset and all these
things and you're like I can't get out
of this and this is how my life is and
this is just how it's gonna be you're
gonna continue to attract other people
who are like yeah I understand what you
mean like life sucks like the weather so
you know all of these things and it's
like well if you say you know hold on a
second
I'd matter i matter and how I show up in
the world matters and how I treat me
matters and it doesn't matter you start
saying that to yourself you go to the
grocery store you have a smile on your
face you're like hey how's it going
today to the checker and he's like wow
thank you so much for being so friendly
and you're like yeah no problem you just
made that guy's day and guess what his
vibration was gonna shift and when he
goes home to his wife and he's in a
better mood that's gonna infect her you
know so we all matter and like realizing
that you do matter regardless of the
story that you tell yourself when you
start to accept that then you start to
make a greater impact in and a bit
greater changing you start to feel that
all's
the eight billion of us are puzzle
pieces and that each one of us matters
in the puzzle of civilization and that
the more that we vibe on a positive
wavelength that we
butterfly effect' out the positivity
yeah yeah totally totally and it's so
crazy you watch that first like tiny
little domino that you have to like push
down with like a tweezer yes and it just
goes yep
and it takes down a domino like the size
of this room and the very last one and
it's just so loud and you're like how
did that small one do that and so that's
the beauty of social butterfly effect'
yeah okay there's still so much to talk
about I want to hit this because you
mentioned this earlier there's you work
a lot with men and we're kind of going
through a it's a strange ish period yeah
because a lot of civilization is built
by the patriarchy and the economic
machinery of growing these businesses
and providing the ubiquity and food and
electricity and water and shelter and
all these things while simultaneously
there's been a severe disconnect from
Mother Earth and men need to open up for
vulnerability for connection to these
what we feel and engaging other men and
women on that and children on that level
so teach us about what this practice has
been like with other men
so it's interesting like a little story
my background being in yoga obviously
anyone who's walked into yoga studio
knows that 75 to 90% of the people in a
yoga class are women moving into
nutrition and helping work with diet and
detox as a form of helping people
connect deeper to themselves again I
started noticing that eighty to ninety
percent of my clientele were women and
then I just started to kind of take a
step back and start to ask other people
in my field such as doctors holistic
therapist even chiropractors and ask
them you know what is your ratio from
male to female and the majority of
people would say primarily female right
and it could vary anywhere from sixty
forty to seventy thirty to whatever I
started just to take a second and step
back and say well that doesn't make
sense right because women our bodies
aren't any less functional or less you
know like we're no less functional than
men what's really going on here and I
started to ask a certain question I sort
of asked all the men around me and I've
always been like the one woman with like
a lot of male friends in my life and I
just started to ask that and most of
them were like well we're taught not to
ask for help like toughen up be a big
boy put your big-boy pants on don't show
your emotions like you know like you
need to get out there get back on the
field all of these different things it's
like this repressive structure that has
disconnected men from feeling that they
could be open and honest and create
super deep true like heartfelt
connections with other men which creates
more competition which creates more
scarcity which means we take more from
the earth which means there's more
scarcity in love which means like that's
the center of everything that we all
really want and so I started also
feeling that like because there's a lot
of pressure for men around the story
around how men need to be for women they
need to be the providers they need to be
the support they need to be the
protectors that they also and I've heard
from many men it's like well the moment
that we do
down at the moment that we do get soft
it's like women want us to be soft and
vulnerable but the moment that we do
it's like they can't hold us they can't
support us and then it's like well here
you want me to be yours rockin your
supporter when you're feeling emotional
but what about me I'm like hearing that
from men was like oh my gosh like and I
can see that and I can feel that and so
I think that there's this you know
that's what made me say well hold on a
second I just want to work with men for
a while and I want to start hosting
men's circles as a woman saying hey
especially with all this me to movement
and all of this I was really irritated
by the way that we were turning it
around becoming the victims and then
acting with anger and rage as women and
all of these things I said I want to
stand with the men because I know that
there's another side that we're that
they're not taught they're taught don't
share your emotions don't speak into
your emotions women can wail and cry and
all these things and it's okay
but if a man do it you're not manly and
so I said I want to stand on their side
and I want to start holding space and
allowing them to drop in and to let go
of their armor and to let down their
shields and to feel into this part of
them that is just dying to be felt and
so yeah that's kind of how like my work
with men started and I really feel that
we're all just trying to recognize our
masculine and our feminine which are
just different energies that are wanting
to be expressed in in the right time in
the right place with the right people in
the right moment so that we can
understand each other and have this
beautiful relationship whether it's you
know from woman to man or woman's a
woman or human to earth or what have you
yeah yeah that's so well said we're I
can speak for a decent amount of of men
that I interact with as well that we
talk a lot about the hierarchy we talk a
lot about the need to climb up this
hierarchy that there's this rage to try
and gain influence and clout and you
know have a higher level of genetic
fitness that way you can get yourself a
better mate yeah that these things are
so much programmed in and that while
simultaneously a lot of that is
biological imperative we have socially
constructed a civilization that has made
it that so much the the the code the
main code that the the other code of
tapping into to deeper levels of
stewardship or compassion or love or
vulnerability has in the sense taken a
backseat to that and I'm glad that
you've that you've passed time with men
helping them with these circles of
conversation around these topics is I
would love to even open up the studio
space for these types we were talking to
you know Vika Victoria yesterday from
brave new men about this as well Amanda
baked them as well why don't we do let's
invite these guys that were that we
talked to about hierarchies and climbing
and let's have a roundtable about that
with you leading and let's see what
comes up because a lot of things would
come up a lot and to be able to have
content that shows that hey men can be
vulnerable
men can reflect inward on what is truly
their moat their emotional state their
divine purpose and have an open
conversation about that I think is there
will help us a lot moving into this
crazy exponential technology age where
there's a billion of us and the
geopolitical climate is changing so much
and I think if we like if we come back
to this idea of just reconnecting to
ourselves you can have you can climb the
letter you can have a success you can
have the fitness you can do all those
things and you can do it in a way that's
more with integrity that's more or less
about you and your own stride and more
about like how am I doing this for
something greater and how do my actions
like affect something bigger like
there's nothing like the masculine it's
been beautiful it's gotten us to where
we are it's a beautiful aspect of every
single human here there's nothing wrong
with competition it's about how are we
funneling this energy and is it in a
deeper rooted sense for something beyond
the ego beyond the self right and I
think that's where we're we're coming
back to it's like wait a second like I
can have all the things in the world but
if it's not rooted in something bigger
than I feel alone with all these things
you know yes in said when I've had the
opportunity to look at the mirror it
thanks to mentors of mine that have said
no Allen seriously look how ego driven
are you how selfish are you how greedy
are you and I've really had to like cry
because I'm like holy [ __ ] these things
are how is it possible that these things
are really within me and then having the
practice of working on how I feel about
it and really working on having that
trance being it being about transcendent
the channeling of the ideas through to
inspire and engage being having that be
a transcendent experience that is not
about the ego that it's not about the
selfishness that that is what has been
like a key growth pillar and I hope I
hope that that ends up being the one
that takes us through that exponential
technology and geopolitical age because
then now really drive us to that unity
and cohesion okay couple quick questions
on the way out that we
asking our guest has been such a great
episode we'll have to do this more often
when you come through the area after you
go to Europe and come back yes yes okay
first question are we alone in the
cosmos No
I mean to elaborate right no I mean I
don't I don't feel I don't feel that at
all I feel like there's so much more I
mean I think it's ignorant for us to
think that we're are the only things
that are here and the only things that
exist like just look at it on a
logistical scale if you want to how
small we are and how big the world is
like I think it's easy to to see that
were there's so much more and then the
next question is are we in a simulation
maybe could be you know like I believe
we are the creators of our own reality
so it depends on what scope you want to
you know how big you want to step back
from that right
so a little deeper so I mean if we are
the creators of our own reality and
we're in this space and we're navigating
you know this dream it's like a dream
right
then one day we'll wake up from the
dream and maybe you call that death but
you're waking up from this understanding
that we were collecting we were pure
consciousness from the very beginning it
all began and we're just here in this 3d
world experiencing this dimension of
matter which is so beautiful and also
funny in the bigger picture of it all so
like one day I feel that the death is
really just waking up from the dream
that we created being in this like fun
yeah tangible reality it's my story
anyway well we the next time we sit down
together we have to spend a decent chunk
of time talking about that aspect of
spirituality being these roleplay
characters in the game and it's funny
this is funny 3d which is like when
there's like crazy dramatic things that
are happening like okay and it's a part
of life and like see it and accept it
and don't be ignorant but like also like
kind of laugh at it and then choose to
again focus on the things that you can
control yeah right in our last question
what is the most beautiful thing in the
world
mmm the ability to experience this felt
sense of presence and what that means in
each and every moment
that's what I think that's what I feel
yeah constant constant kindergarten
trying to learn how to do that you know
better and better throughout the whole
3d experience yeah breath helps breath
helps a lot yeah
gratitude helps a lot yeah and slowing
down slowing down slowing down giving
yourself space Amanda you are so fun I
had such a good time listing you thank
you so much for coming on the show thank
you it's been amazing to be here and
thank you for inviting me into this nice
studio in the middle of like this crazy
mecca of San Francisco thank you we love
you we love your work a lot thank you so
much for coming on thank you thank you
and huge take you to Ron Vargas for
producing and directing we love you very
much thank you huge thank you to
everyone for tuning in thank you thank
you thank you we would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode tell us what you think holistic
health mindfulness let us know in your
comments below also share more
conversation with your friends families
co-workers online about holistic health
and mindfulness get talking more about
it to each other go and check out Amanda
become calm the links are below to all
of Amanda's we're going to check it out
subscribe to her YouTube etc and support
the artists entrepreneurs and
organizations around the world that you
believe it supports simulation our links
are below help us continue scaling and
impact with more people and go and build
the future everyone manifest your divine
sole purpose into the world we love you
very much thank you for tuning in and we
will see you soon
[Music]
[Music]